the streets of niger's capital Naomi
remained calm but the military coup
leaders show no sign of backing down
instead announcing more new officials to
replace the government of democratically
elected president Muhammad bahrazum who
they have held in detention since July
the 26th the president the president of
the National Council for the
safeguarding of the Homeland head of
state decrees Article 1 Mr lamine Zane
Ali Muhammad is appointed prime minister
all diplomatic efforts at finding a
peaceful solution to the crisis have so
far failed
in its latest response the military
Junta said it had refused entry to a
delegation from the African Union the
U.N and the regional block ecowas
because of security concerns
this only hours after the acting U.S
deputy secretary of state Victoria
Newland said she had held two hours of
difficult talks with a self-appointed
defense minister and had been refused
access to niger's detained leader the
U.S says it Still Remains hopeful
diplomacy can work the window of
opportunity is definitely still open we
believe that uh the Hooters should step
aside and allow president bazoom to
resume his duties tomorrow today
tomorrow anytime in the near future
ecowas is struggling to pull together a
military force comprised of soldiers
from member states which it has
threatened to use as a last resort in a
potential military operation to
reinstate the deposed Nigerian president
Nigeria's president Bola tinubu is the
new chairman of ecowas
Nigeria with by far the biggest army in
the region would be expected to take the
lead in any such military operation
but president sunubu is facing
opposition from Nigerian MPS including
those in his own party and his people
who fear the considerable risk of
sparking a wider Regional War and if
that were to happen it could lead to a
deterioration in the already difficult
fight against armed groups like Boko
Haram isil and Al-Qaeda we have multiple
levers on which we can leverage uh to
achieve uh the end uh that we are
seeking to achieve which is to uphold
the ecowas protocols by ensuring that
there is a return of Civilian Democratic
rule under the leadership of President
bazoom the refusal by niger's coup
leaders to allow entry into the country
by a combined United Nations African
Union and echoas delegation comes two
days before a second emergency ecos
Summit on the crisis it's expected the
focus of that Summit will be discussions
about a potential Last Resort military
solution
The Diplomatic Avenues are still open
but there are fears that they are
becoming increasingly slim Channel
Stratford Al Jazeera the car
foreign